everything in life you're going to have
to at one point uh on a when you're on a
run of obsession you're sacrificing all
these athletes we admire that you follow
Kobe Bryant's sacrifice personal time
with his family 20 years of playing 82
games 41 on the road playoffs Olympics
you think that's a peaceful life
military generals General Mattis we
admire 35-year service you know he's in
you know War for you think you're you're
a good father I haven't seen my kid nine
years out of the last 18 years my kid
was you know at the house I was at War I
was on you think that's you put that as
a great father what do you how do you
describe that so the definition of all
of these things it's very to him his
mind is if these generals are at War
doing what they're doing I'm simply
doing my war in business competing
against these guys and I see my kids
where I've taken place and we have a
good time but I'm like the general
that's at War I don't see my kids for a
year and a half for a year I see myself
same as that I think that's his
processing